just a couple of years ago if you wanted
to share a file it was a warped Sheriff
outside the organization it was mud of
pain and bureaucracy now in the cloud
it's it is just three clicks and it's
almost immediate and so you get this
autonomous themes that are using data
and they own the data they own their
applications and they can innovate fast
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today I'm with Amit shakid the
CEO and co-founder of laminar chaquette
served in unit 8200 of the Israel
Defense Forces and Israeli intelligence
core unit focused on Signal intelligence
and code decryption before co-funding
laminar of course chuck had earned the
masters of green artificial intelligence
and deep learning during his time in the
military and after unit 8200 he led deep
learning Ai and augmented reality teams
for the unicorn magic leap Amit holds a
masters of computer science from Tel
Aviv University
foreign
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being here how are you
I'm great thank you so much for inviting
me very excited to be here
really excited to have you here as well
um working on some really really cool
stuff with laminar
um you know looking at an emerging
industry challenges that that are hugely
relevant today for so many organizations
and I'm looking forward to diving deep
into what that means for you and for the
company and for the for the world as a
whole and and so I'm just excited to
talk to you for these 20 minutes thank
you again for being here
yes of course and we also have quite a
lot in common so be interesting to to
hear about that 100 100 so I mean to
tell me how this whole thing started you
know from your from your perspective
yeah so I think it goes all the way back
to the house I grew up in so my father
is is a patriot right it's about nice
Primo roles and strong values and we'll
do everything for for the right cause he
was a commander at Israeli Wars so it's
also about high sense of responsibility
of accountability of taking care of of
your people right but at the same time
he is extremely optimistic so he wakes
up with a smile every day he loves the
world loves the people believes in the
goodness of people
now my mother was born at the Soviet
Union and that's a bit different so I
was ready to raised with a more Russian
education and that's about working how
yeah it's about working hard training
hard about mind over body controlling
your emotions and about being the best
version of yourself now that was always
has always been my blessing and my curse
because it's not about being better than
that other people right and it's not
even about being objectively good at
what you do it's about being the best
version of yourself and so when I got
you know perfect grades at high school I
I told her that and she was like that's
nice but can you do better but can you
be better and so to me I thought well
yes and so I started my bachelor's read
high school and then it kind of stick
with me this understanding this
stressness to be the best version of
myself and when I started or got
selected to the unit A200 I thought well
that's nice but can I do better better
and so I wanted to be the commander or
get the commander Excellence award for
from the unity 200 Commander and so you
see where this is going every step of my
career was was about that now if you are
an ambitious teenager that is very
optimistic maybe perhaps overly
optimistic
version of themselves hey what do you do
now in Israel there's almost only one
answer and that's becoming an
entrepreneur yeah and so for those who
don't know there's an atmospheric
culture in Israel that almost realize uh
entrepreneurs and so for me from very
very early stage I knew that I want to
build my own company I knew that I want
to be the the CEO even before I knew
what it means before I knew anything
about entrepreneurship before I knew any
of the sacrifices I'll have to make I
knew that this is going to be my way and
so there was a kind of the way I planned
my my career and I was also very lucky
to meet my co-founder and CEO at Theo
sorry or run at around the same age so
we're both 14 doing the bachelor's
degree together during high school and I
knew from the very beginning that is
just something else he is out of this
world it was the best Technologies I
ever knew and I can tell you one story
about Iran that kind of shows why I
wanted him to be the CTO from from back
then there so at around age 17 or run it
bought an iPhone in the U.S and then
brought it to Israel but couldn't use it
because it was locked for atnt so he
discovered he decided to discover the
first iPhone 3G based on vulnerability
that allowed me to unlock the iPhone I
use it with any carrier that are using
or have used iPhone it's thanks to all
right and so we thought we knew that we
want to start a company together when we
were planning that since 8 40 and so the
only question was what are we going to
do and when do we want to start so we
planned our careers I went to be the
oran started as the first employee at a
very successful startup and I wanted to
be an employee in a larger startup so
with about a thousand employees to see
how things work work at scale and then
when it was the right time they we
decided to start a company and basically
the I mean we were always asking about
himself it's like the state of mind
about the world which is always asking
what's from with the word and what would
be the impact if we improve it by by 10x
and so we had many ideas along the way
but then at the first time that the
answer was this is going to change the
world then we left our jobs and started
laminar
so tell me about that sort of that
understanding what what did you sort of
think about that gave you that
understanding okay this is going to
change the world
so basically
I had passion for data and machine
learning so that the passion for that
evolved over time it started with just
passing passion for technology and back
in 2015 deep learning and AI was the
most promising technology out there and
so I wanted to do something with data
that will make an impact but then after
some time of doing that I realized that
a way to do way more impact or orders of
magnitude more effect is not by
leveraging data myself but rather to
unlock the potential of data and to
enable Enterprises all over the world to
use data more freely as kit and so
that's where can laminar came in because
we realized that the main obstacle or
the main challenge for companies to use
data freely is data security like there
are others and others that are coming
but data security was the major
challenge so we wanted to tackle this
first yeah and this is how
we wanted to start at the company
okay so data cloud data security you
know what what was it about sort of the
urgency and the the emergence of this of
of data and Cloud that that led you to
understand that okay this is something
that's really big right now
yeah sure that's a great question
because the main main transformation in
four businesses or the Way businesses
operate in the past few years is the
cloud confirmation so organizations are
now moving applications and data to the
cloud and the cloud is not only makes
making things more efficient it actually
enables the developers and the data
scientists to use data more free so if
just a couple of years ago if you wanted
to share a file it was or share a file
outside the organization it was month of
pain and bureaucracy now in the cloud
it's it is just three clicks that it's
almost immediate and so you get this
autonomous themes that are using data
and they own the data they own their
applications and they can innovate fast
and so the problem is that today
security does not stick to the data and
so with data proliferates in the cloud
security does not trouble with it and so
what again is a lot of innovation a lot
of data proliferation but that creates
or come at the costs of a data risk and
so this is white storage now
organizations wants to democratize data
but at the same time decouple the risk
from the growth
and so the you know what I'm hearing is
that we have many more data sources
proliferation I mean obviously
microservices Cloud infrastructure Etc
and and that while we have this
proliferation sort of this exponential
growth we don't have the right tools to
Monitor and to understand what's
happening and how to keep secured and so
what is the opportunity that laminar
then presents in in sort of this new Gap
that you're observing in the market
yeah sure so there are tools for cloud
security but today they all focus on the
infrastructure so it's about maybe
protecting your main database but the
problem is as soon as the data moves it
is copied to any other environment for
an experiment or for using data for on
purpose data security does not check
with but then when we look at data
security what we find are only solutions
for the Enterprise for the old
environment a Solutions like different
dlps or file scanning or database
scanning but there's nothing really for
everything you build in running the
cloud nothing that protects your data
there and this is what laminars take
no is that mainly sort of an
observability type of of understanding
or is that something that that is also
meant to protect it you know without
your observability just by virtue of of
you having access to it sort of what is
the inter what is the sort of the
product that laminar is is creating in
the space
yeah great question so basically yes
there are lack of solutions for this
style environment around data security
but what it means is basically that
companies today don't have answers to
the most fundamental questions where is
the data how it is protected and who has
access to it and this is crazy right
it's the most fundamental question
system the place where you want to start
to protect your data and still there are
no easy answers right so there's a lot
of manual effort right now that is
undergoing to try and answer these
questions because you have to but what
langdar is doing is we automate all this
process from the very beginning from the
discovery so we connect to the cloud
environment and then we discover all the
data we classified we understand the
context and the ownership for the data
we walk them through how it is currently
protected and how it can be better
protected all the way to monitoring
real-time data accesses to detect if
something is going wrong if there's a
databe Creator data ex filtration
malicious or or an incident so it's an
end-to-end cloud data security platform
for everything to build a mailing
account
now from a technology perspective you're
coming from an AI background so tell me
a little bit about some of the
interesting technologies that that are
enabling you to be you know because
obviously we're talking about so many
data sources so many data points how do
you even identify you know what are some
maybe points of vulnerability or even
things that to help to help the company
prioritize on what to put their
attention on because you know limited
Human Resources lots and lots of data
that's accumulating exponentially
yeah that's a great question because the
cloud is not only the source for the
problem that we're solving but it also
the source for the better solution that
we can provide because obviously data
security is not is not a new problem
right it's as all this data itself but
the thing is all the traditional
Solutions didn't have much
infrastructure to work with and so they
couldn't really work at scale and I'll
maybe just give one example to
understand how hard it was before
laminar to to secure data you had to go
data source by data source and connect
the traditional solution to this data
source in order to scan and understand
to providing the credentials now imagine
that you have thousands of data stores
in the cloud and you don't even know
there are credentials for all of them we
are not going to do this one by one and
also it misses all the data that you
didn't know you have it's what's called
Shadow data and that's very common
phenomenon in the club and so what
laminar is doing the key Innovation is
just by using the cloud service provider
apis we are able to do everything from
the discovery through the classification
all the way to protection and real-time
monitoring including prevention and that
is
insane I think that's really something
that wasn't possible before the cloud
transformation and so what you get from
this technology is the ease of use is
the time to Value you don't need to grow
data source by data source you don't
need month tops onboarding you just
connect laminar to your Cloud within
five minutes and you immediately get all
the information you want about where
it's your data how it is protected and
who has access to it so you can start to
remediate the issues and reduce the risk
of your flower environment
is there any consideration of trust
building between you and and sort of the
people that are integrating laminar into
their into their Cloud because then
obviously you you do have you know you
you it's not necessarily visibility but
you but you're sort of helping them
understand sort of their data structures
and and thereby you're you're part of
the process so is that even a question
that you have to deal with how do you
Garner trust between yourself and the
companies that are using laminar
yeah absolutely so if you put yourself
from the perspective of the Enterprise
right they know they have many data
security issues they don't want to
create another one by sending all their
data to this new course and so out of
our technology and a key differentiator
is that everything is running within the
customer environment so we're using
serverless functions no agents just to
run on the customer environment and we
only send the metadata back home so this
is a new approach we're able to run
everything in the cloud we're able to
test everything locally but when it
actually runs none of the sensitive data
leaves their environment and so this is
what contributes to creating and
building distrust because we're not
sending any new data
um okay that makes a lot of sense tell
me a little bit about sort of the growth
of laminar and you've raised significant
amounts of money from some great
investors and
um tell me a little bit about sort of
the trajectory of the company where
you're at today and and where you're
aiming for
yeah thank you so I think one of the
most exciting things especially for
investors is the market opportunity and
we have investors like one of the two of
the largest investors in the world it's
tiger Global and inside partners and
they manage funds of or assets of more
than a hundred billion dollars worth of
assets and so they don't really care
about about a unicorn by the billion
dollar for them won't even return far
what they really care about are
companies that are going to change
the word right is going to change
businesses and create a huge opportunity
and so for us we start with security or
cloud data security as this is the main
enabler for organizations to use data
more freely to democratize the data to
have data Centric Innovation but that's
just the start because what we have is a
unique view of all the data that the
Enterprise has and so now there are
other use cases for privacy right we all
know about customer privacy and everyone
wants to to keep their data safe and
it's about the the the trust between the
company and their users so there are
many use cases there that were currently
not pendling but this is on the roadmap
on top of privacy there is all data
management so it's about not security
and not privacy but how can you use the
data more efficiently how can you reduce
the time to buy how can you improve the
results by using the most updated data
and so this is part of the new role for
the chief data officer they are thinking
about how to monetize data how to use
this as as a key differentiator and so
that's a whole new world of useful that
we can can do too and so that is going
to cover the next five years or so and
so the vision is to not it is to be the
cloud beta platform right that covers
all the different use cases around data
what are you most excited about you know
we started the conversation a little bit
about sort of your own motivation as an
entrepreneur yeah you know going back to
a little bit about your own mindset and
of Excellency and pushing the boundaries
how does that play into what you're
doing now
yeah so
I think the thing I'm most excited about
is maybe surprising and not surprising
at the same time it is
the every time that I see our employees
becoming best friends when they didn't
even know each other before that so the
understanding that we've built something
so huge that connects people globally
and now they became best friends to me
it's just uh just so exciting to see and
in terms of pushing the boundaries I
think that
in a way shaping a new market is one of
the most high risk High reward kind of
tests because as surprising and it may
sound cloud data security is is a new
market and so there weren't really
solutions that we just replaced with
better Technologies it's it's a blue
ocean and this is so exciting because it
takes a lot of creativity it takes a lot
of
Partnerships and understanding of the
ecosystem of the partners of the of the
our customers right so it's about your
Innovation around the market opportunity
and around the business and it gets
exciting every day so every quarter now
the company looks different than the
previous quarter as we continue to grow
rapidly and to me every day every month
every quarter every year I'm just
pushing more and more my boundaries
because if I haven't learned anything
new in the past month then it wasn't it
was probably not a good month right
I love it Amit thank you so much for
taking the time to share at least 20
minutes with me best of luck with
lemonade sounds like you're working on
something you're you're personally
hugely passionate about it sounds like
very very high impact and something that
the world really needs and many
organizations need and and I love the
sort of the your core understandings of
at the end you're you were looking to go
after a huge world problem and that has
a significant impact to obviously have
some fantastic backers that
um that that you know really embody sort
of that type of spirit and mentality so
best of luck with leminar and uh thank
you again for taking the time to be here
I appreciate it foreign
[Music]